speaking in new music so one of your new
songs joanna
it kind of pushes against the media a
bit it's like could you talk about that
song a little bit
absolutely yeah so my name is joanna
that's my real name
um and it's just like
fans or or just people on online
sometimes
refer to me as joanna people think they
they know you
or people think that they can draw
conclusions and this is less about the
media and more about kind of this cancel
culture that is so prevalent right now
wow especially you know on social media
and we're just so quick to write people
off
you know people need to be held
accountable for heinous things
that that's some people i understand you
know why
there's this this quickness to do that
but
when it comes to like saying someone's
peaked or they
they're done their career is over
because you haven't seen them in a few
months or a few years
that's just so ridiculous to me so
that's kind of what what the song is
about it's like
um everybody's just one moment
away from you know redemption or
evolution or
being back chapter is exactly like you
can't write anybody off and i'm
low-key a prime example of that so
that's kind of what the song is about